[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mardi 15 janvier lors du
7-8 journal sur tv 78 bienvenue dans
cette édition tout de suite les titres
de l'actualité locale
il a été voulu par le président de la
république pour répondre à la crise des
gilet jaune le grand débat national a
été lancé aujourd'hui c'est jusqu'au 15
mars est les français pourront déposer
des contributions et participer à des
réunions d'initiative locale nous en
parlons avec pierre lui ce nouveau
référent de la république en marche dans
les yvelines
invité de ce journal également ans
thomas bourdeau directeur territorial
d'aînés 10 dans le département le groupe
a engagé de grands investissements en
2018 sur le territoire quel est le bilan
dressé après une année marquée par des
aléas climatiques nous ferons le point
aussi sur le déploiement des compteurs
linky
enfin un one man show s'était proposé à
la commanderie à del en cours samedi un
spectacle imaginé par françois sauvageau
l objectif comprendre les mathématiques
tout en s amusant de lourdes peines
infligées le tribunal de versailles a
condamné à 3 ans hier trois personnes
pardon pour blessures et homicide
involontaire après le décès de la petite
maeva 13 en souvenez vous en 2014
elle a perdu la vie dans un accident de
manège à la fête foraine de
flins-sur-seine et deux ans de prison
dont un avec sursis pour le forain aux
commandes de la traction l'agent
contrôleur est condamné à 15 mois de
prison avec sursis une interdiction
d'exercer pour un an le maire de
flins-sur-seine lui écope d'une amende
de 11 mille cinq cents euros dans dix
jours le manège toujours en activité
devra être démantelée flins sur seine où
le groupe renault est implanté tout
comme un cul en cours son pdg carlos
ghosn va rester en prison aujourd'hui le
tribunal de tokyo a de nouveau rejeté sa
demande de libération sous caution
il est détenu au japon depuis une
cinquantaine de jours pour des soupçons
de malversations financières à la tête
de l'alliance avec nissan est le
dirigeant devrait rester en détention
préventive jusqu'au 10 mars son éviction
de renault n'est pour le moment est pas
aisée évoquée
j'accueille tout de suite sur ce plateau
mon premier invité pierre luçon soir
bonsoir
vous êtes nommé vous a été nommé le 7
janvier référent départemental des
yvelines pour la république on marche on
va en parler dans un instant
forcément évoqué d'abord avec vous cette
actualité le grand débat national il a
été lancé aujourd'hui elle les français
pourront jusqu'au 15 mars faire augmenté
des contributions participé aussi à des
réunions locales autour de quatre grands
thèmes la fiscalité les dépenses
publiques l'organisation de l'état est
la transition écologique quatrième thème
la démocratie et la citoyenneté
est ce que c'est une bonne réponse
apportée à cette crise des gilets jaunes
que connaît le pays et maintenant depuis
le 17 novembre
écoutez oui c'est une bonne réponse
c'est je pense ce qu'il fallait faire
pour prendre l'avis de tous y compris à
des gens qu'on n'entend pas forcément
notre pays est marqué par des scrutins
avec une forte abstention
si l'écran qui sont éloignés du
processus électoral éloignés de leurs
élus ce qui fait aussi que les élus se
sont éloignés de ces populations là
c'est important d'aller voir tout le
monde
effectivement il ya eu des réactions
contrastées après la révélation de la
lettre des manuels macro où il a il a
cadré ce grand débat national 32
questions posées il fallait que le
président de la république explique la
démarche c'était aussi important bien
sûr beaucoup trop lassés de réactions
contrastées
je pense beaucoup de défiance aussi des
gens qui manquent de confiance envers
cette démarche c'est à nous de restaurer
cette confiance
alors d'après un sondage de oddo que ça
pour nos confrères de france info 70 %
des français estiment que cette grande
consultation elle n'aboutira pas à des
mesures utiles pour le pays ça veut dire
que c'est perdu d'avancé
ce grand débat national non c'est un
défi un défi qu'il nous faut relever et
j'ai bon espoir qu'en travaillant tous
ensemble on arrive à le relever et à
montrer à ces gens qui peut nous faire
confiance sur ce duo on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler mais à partir du 21
janvier c'est un site qui va être mise
en place le grand débat grand débat
point fr pardon qui sera mise en place
auprès des français ils pourront mettre
leurs contributions directement sur ce
site internet des contributions qu'ils
pourront envoyer aussi via la poste ou
des à des points de passage le site
permettra également de connaître les
lieux de réunions locales d'organiser
aussi sa réunion l'ingrédient pour que
ça marche ce débat il faut que les
citoyens se saisissent de ce grand débat
il faut que les citoyens s'en saisissent
qu'ils participent à tous qui sera mis
alors disposition pour s'exprimer que ce
soit le site internet que ce soit les
quelques doléances que certains maires
mettent en mairie et aussi les réunions
qui seront organisées bach appelle tous
les maires des yvelines à mettre à
disposition de l'ensemble des mouvements
politiques et des associations des
salles gratuite pour pouvoir organiser
ces réunions c'est pas toujours évident
d'avoir des salles gratuite ou alors il
ya des conditions
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que dans
toutes les communes des yvelines
n'importe quel mouvement politique
puisse organiser gratuitement une
réunion sans avoir à payer de location
de ça c'est un préalable à la réussite
que les les maires aussi participent à
ce grand débat on a tous un rôle à jouer
et le président de la quick été très
clair sur le rôle que doivent avoir les
maires dans ces bars 8 mai dans les
yvelines dont on connaît déjà le nom du
référent de la préfecture pour ce grand
débat il s'agit de vincent roberti qui
aura plus un rôle de facilitateur et non
d'organisateurs et ce qu'on sait comment
ça va se mettre en place dans les
yvelines peut-être déjà des lieux de
réunions qui sont établies alors que
quelques pas connaissance de
l'organisation institutionnelle du débat
pour ce qui concerne la partie organisée
par l'état et par par les maires en ce
qui concerne la réplique en marche nous
prendront part à ce débat d'une partie
des gars en organisant en lire une
contribution par les marcheurs qui est
il sera organisée nationalement
l'ofac département contribuera avec des
ateliers des tables rondes des réunions
internes et en plus nous on tient à
mettre sur le terrain nos adhérents pour
qu'ils aillent faire du porte à porte
pour mobiliser en fait les citoyens y
compris là on ne voit jamais on est
souvent en gare on est souvent sur les
marchés il ya plainte à deux endroits où
on ne va pas souvent il faut aller
chercher les personnes crise elles pour
leur dire allez participer au grand
débat les réunions et les seuls sites
internet envoyer vos contributions
on est à votre écoute mais après cette
phase de recueil des contributions
précises qu'à partir du 1er mars des
réunions générales seront organisées
avec des citoyens qui seront tirés au
sort et aussi différents représentants
et d'où découleront au final des
propositions concrètes
alors vous avez été
mais c'est le deuxième thème de cette
interview référent de la république en
marche des yvelines vous avez succédé à
shenzhen est à l'aib vous êtes habitants
de maurepas vous avez 30 ans cadre d'une
start-up dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle et de la
santé et vous étiez à l'origine des tout
premiers comités de la république en
marche dans les zivis tête à elancourt
dans ce que vous avez fait aussi pour la
république en main je vous avait
notamment dirigé la campagne du député
didier baichère lors des législatives
celle de martin lévriers aux
sénatoriales
comment vous aborder cette nouvelle
fonction celle de référents des yvelines
ne l'abordent avec beaucoup de sérénité
l'espoir parce que je porte un projet de
rassemblement et d'action pour le
mouvement dans les yvelines
merci beaucoup de messages de fixation
de gens qui sont très contents qu'on est
en référence à la procédure a duré un
peu de temps et les camps sont ravis
pouvoir repasser à l'action revenir sur
le terrain on va essayer de retrouver un
peu les fondamentaux du mouvement ceux
qui sont nés avec la grande marche en
2016 et qui nous avait amené des gars
aller frapper à toutes les portes
à l'époque qui avait a permis de
remonter énormément de deux
problématiques qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui dans celles qui sont
remontés dans beaucoup nous l'avait dit
la procédure était donc si vous aviez
fait acte de candidature dès septembre
avec six autres candidats pourquoi vous
étiez alignés c'est ça c'était de
repartir dans cette démarche qui a été
la république en marche
au tout début de ce mondial c'est ce que
je voulais c'est ce que j'ai donné comme
comme mouvement à mon projet c'était
vraiment qu'on devienne le mouvement
qu'on était à la base d un mouvement de
citoyens qui voulaient faire la
politique autrement et qui soit à
l'écouté de la population
quel est le rôle d'un référent
départemental le rôle de référent
départemental il est assez simple s'agit
de mobiliser les adhérents de les aider
à se structurer en comités locaux de
porter assistance à ses comités
c'est à dire quand ils ont besoin d'un
financement pour un progrès quand ils
ont besoin d'un accompagnement près
l'élu que ce soit pour ça et évidemment
de travail et politiquement au progrès
de différents projets locaux qu'on peut
avoir à mener merci à pierre lux d'être
que vous passez sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le nouveau
référent de la république en marche dans
les yvelines
pour être complet d'ailleurs sur la
république en marché sur le président de
la république emmanuel macron va réunir
lundi prochain 150 chefs d'entreprises
français et étrangers au château de
versailles un sommet à nommer tous
france des restrictions de circulation
sont à prévoir on vous en fera pas sur
ce journal est dans l'actualité
également le site de so frappe un
attrape va fermer le 31 mai la décision
a été annoncée lors d'un comité
d'entreprise extraordinaire
ir lundi l usine l'une des première
boulangerie industrielle installée en
france est présent dans la ville depuis
50 ans 73 emplois en cdi sont concernées
mais se fera pas indique proposer des
solutions de reclassement
elles ne correspondent pas aux
qualifications des salariés d'après
force ouvrière à la recherche d'un
repreneur pour le site a été confiée à
un spécialiste
c'était une première dimanche s'est
déroulée la journée nationale de
l'hypersensibilité c'est ressentir des
émotions de manière intense ou amplifier
et sans filtre pour l'occasion manon
baradeau s'est rendu à la maison des
arts de morcourt ou des ateliers étaient
organisés
reportage dimanche 13 janvier 2010 neuf
premières journées nationales d hyper
sensible de l'histoire
en france plus de 10 millions de
personnes sont concernées nos sens sont
exacerbés
on peut être ému par plein de choses de
manière beaucoup plus forte que d'autres
on peut se sentir inadaptée aussi au
monde tel qu'il est parce que c'est
vraiment un monde assez dur qui nous
entoure et on peut sans se sentir
vraiment par les hyper sensibles ont
souvent une grande créativité qu'ils ont
pu exprimer leurs de l'atelier 2 s'offre
aux créations proposées par
l'association cubique au ma créativité
est un outil pour passer de ce qui peut
être ressenti comme souffrant à quelque
chose qui devient justement porter voire
joyeux en tout cas qui devient une façon
de produire quelque chose avec ceux
qu'on aime
crayons feutres les participantes ont pu
laisser sortir leurs élans de créativité
renforcée par un état de relaxation
c'était une première expérience de
sophrologie j'étais curieuse de savoir
qu'est ce qu'on peut ressentir par
rapport à la création puisque je crème
et je suis assez mental donc c'est
difficile de me libérer de l'intérieur
libérer sa sensibilité autres
possibilités avec l'atelier d'écriture
pour un public de gens forcément
sensible à bien par les cris on va
pouvoir leur proposer de parler d'eux
mêmes et pour ces gens là c'est souvent
difficile
tous les ateliers se sont déroulés en
petits groupes dans une atmosphère
bienveillante la journée nationale de
l'hypersensibilité se déroulera
désormais chaque année le 13 janvier il
ya un nouveau sujet une nouvelle invitée
avec moi en plateau thomas bourdeau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
territorial d'aînés 10 dans les yvelines
alors le groupe gère bien sûr le réseau
d'électricité en france est l'occasion
de parler avec vous de l'actualité des
nez dit c'est aussi des compteurs linky
est déjà ce chiffre plus de 60 millions
d'euros ont été investis par le groupe
sur le seul département des yvelines en
2018 avant de nous dire à quoi ont servi
ces investissements quel bilan global
vous dresser sur cette année 2018 dans
le département le sait marquée notamment
par des aléas climatiques de la neige
des inondations est ce que les équipes
d'aînés 10 ont su faire face à ses
difficultés
absolument alors l'année
2018 a été une année très active pour
nous pour de multiples raisons comme
vous l'avez site et nous augmentons
fortement nos investissements à plus de
60 millions d'euros
ceci pour entretenir le réseau améliorer
la qualité de service pour l'ensemble
des yvelinois
mais c'est aussi pour accompagner le
développement bain des yvelines qui un
département extrêmement dynamique avec
beaucoup de constructions immobilières
beaucoup de projets comme le grand paris
où les jeux olympiques
donc on est en accompagnement alors vous
vous citiez les dites vous voyez ivy
noah pris les devants en ce début
d'année notamment avec les crues de la
seine où la neige qui a pu nous arriver
donc kennedy c'est extrêmement présents
sur ces événements climatiques
alors nous avons notre réponse elle est
toujours double 1 face à ces éléments
climatiques
en premier lieu on intervient pour
mettre en sécurité les biens et les
personnes de façon à ce que tous nos
concitoyens soient en sécurité puis
après on déploie très vite des moyens
humains et matériels pour rétablir le
courant au plus vite donc si on prend
l'exemple du 6 février 2018 où il ya eu
des épisodes de neige assez important eh
ben on avait rétabli la plupart des
courants il avait l'électricité au bout
de la journée pour 92% d'entre eux
voient là et je tiens à rappeler que on
est une entreprise nationale donc en cas
de crise importante on peut faire appel
à d'autres départements
d'autres équipes qui nous amène des
moyens humains et matériels pour pouvoir
renforcer nos équipes
après dans un deuxième temps dans ces
crises là on travaille justement sur nos
investissements de façon à ce que le
réseau électrique soit plus résilient
soit capable de résister grâce et crise
là le vent la neige par exemple donc
c'est notamment sur sur ses travaux sur
le réseau est célèbre et les célèbres
nos investissements interviennent et
c'est là où pour la moitié de ses 60
millions par exemple on remplace
régulièrement des câbles on est amené je
le prendrai deux exemples enfouis en ces
câbles qui sont parfois aérien à les
mettre dans le sol de façon à ce qu'ils
soient moins sensible évidemment
à la neige et au vent ce que l'on fait
aussi c'est qu'on peu surélevé nos
ouvrages on vient d'inaugurer ya pas
longtemps un ouvrage surélever un poste
de transformation à montesson où
justement ben la prochaine fois si la
scène est amené à remonter et ben nos
ouvrages électriques pour les personnes
qui sont le plus proches de la scène
permettront de leur garantir une
alimentation en électricité donc il ya
différents procédés pour que ça soit au
final plus résistants les autres
investissements importants au delà de
rendre le réseau plus plus résistants
quelle honte quelle honte il était alors
on a de nombreux investissements
justement pour accompagner le
développement des lives in je vais en
prendre peut-être deux exemples deux ou
trois le premier c'est qu'on a créé un
tout nouveau poste source
c'est un poste de transformation c'est
un ouvrage industriel assez imposant à
bouin villans nantua d'accord qui va
accompagner le développement de la zone
de menthe leur a menti universités la
zone innova part que la zone des
graviers mais ça va aussi permettre
d'alimenter le rer e eole qui arrive
bientôt
donc ce poste source aussi servir à
sécuriser l'alimentation électrique
c'est à dire que quand on a un incident
un endroit et ben ce nouveau
transformateur pourra prendre le relais
pour éviter que nos clients soient
coupés du courant rien peut-être un
deuxième exemple nous développons un
partenariat très important avec le
syndicat d'énergie des yvelines qui
s'occupe de du de façon très importante
du dossier véhicule électrique et donc
sur ce dossier ils ont prévu de déployer
une centaine de bornes de véhicule
électrique entre 2018 et 2020 et nous
les accompagnons pour raccorder ces
bornes au bon endroit de façon à ce
qu'elle soit utile pour nos concitoyens
mais aussi qu'elle soit au bon endroit
par rapport au réseau électrique de
façon à ce que on optimise le coût de
raccordement à ce réseau est que
l'ensemble soit optimum rapidement qu'on
ait le temps de parler aussi des
compteurs linky en 2019 d'autres
investissements sont prévus avec un
budget similaire
oui alors on augmente encore nos
investissements en 2019 parce que
l'activité vraiment intense dans les
yvelines
je veux citer deux exemples le tram 13
qui va relier saint cyr à saint germain
sur lequel on va faire des
investissements aux alentours de 500
mille euros pour préparer le réseau
électrique or ce tramway
et puis on continue à renouveler nos
câbles aériens souterrains comme tous
les ans en augmentant les montants et
puis on travaille aussi dès maintenant
sur le projet jeux olympiques 2024 avec
le comité d'organisation des jeux
olympiques de façon à préparer la sir la
sécurisation des futurs sites olympiques
qui auront qui seront dans les yvelines
et ça permet de faire la transition est
ce qu'en 2019 vous allez poursuivre le
déploiement de ses fameux compteurs
linky 340000 les anciens compteurs ont
d'ores et déjà été remplacé par ce
compteur électrique intelligent ça va se
poursuivre ce déploiement alors oui le
déploiement a commencé en 2016 se
terminera en 2021 et l'année 2019 comme
l'année 2018 est un peu le l'année de la
cadence maximale pour le déploiement de
compteurs linky dans les yvelines
puisqu'on est environ 1 15 mille côte
15000 compteurs posés par mois et donc
je veux juste rappeler que ce projet
considérable en fait hein on déploie 35
millions de compteurs en france et que
ces compteurs ces nouveaux compteurs
linky ça faire de nombreuses choses que
les anciens compteurs ne savait pas
faire donc noppen notamment accompagné
la transition énergétique
c'est ils sont prêts pour le véhicule
électrique y sont prêts pour les
panneaux photovoltaïques que vous pouvez
poser sur votre toit
et puis il permet de développer des
nouveaux services indispensables pour
nos clients pour la maîtrise de la
consommation de l'énergie pour la relève
à distance plus besoin de prendre rendez
vous plus besoin d'être chez soi pour
tout un tas de services que les
fournisseurs d'électricité vont pouvoir
d'ores et d les propose d'ores et déjà à
tous nos clients qui sont déjà en
possession du comté en multiples
dernière chose dont on entend aussi
beaucoup de choses sur le compteur linky
beaucoup d'inquiétudes notamment sur les
les ongles et l'utilisation des données
il ya aussi cette nouvelle du maire de
magny les hameaux qui a refusé l'accès
aux agents existent pour installer les
nouveaux compteurs linky sur assez sur
les bâtiments communaux et ce qu'elles
sont légitimes ses inquiétudes ou
finances que c'est des idées reçues
alors déjà une première chose le
déploiement du compteur linky dans l'est
dans les yvelines se passe dans de très
bonnes conditions
à aujourd'hui nous avons exactement un
foyer sur deux yvelinois qui dispose du
compteur linky
vous voyez dans la très grande majorité
nos client accepte bien volontiers ce
conteur et comprennent parfaitement les
intérêts qui peut y avoir derrière ce
compteur notamment avec les nouvelles
offres attractives des fournisseurs dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure sur les
ondes et les données alors vous me
donnez l'occasion de réagir là-dessus
pour vous dire que le projet linky a été
l'objet de d'un nombre incroyable de
fake news
enfin on a été extrêmement attaqué sur
ces sujets là à tort notamment sur le
sujet de la santé
le compteur linky n'est totalement
inoffensif pour la santé donc ça je
tiens vraiment à le rappeler à nos
téléspectateurs pour exemple sur les
ondes il aimait 100 fois moins qu un fer
à repasser
donc vous voyez on est vraiment
extrêmement loin d'un niveau
d'exposition aux ondes important ce
n'est pas nous est né dix qui le disons
c'est l' agence nationale des fréquences
radio qui a fait des études très
poussées ils sont avec des experts
extrêmement sérieux sur la question et
qui ont confirmé que le compteur linky
était absolument inoffensifs en termes
dont bhl est inoffensif sur la santé de
conclure ce qu'on arrive à la fin de
centre
cet entretien donc c'est si les faits
que nous en tout cas sur les ondes c'est
absolument sur les données nous mettons
en place de nombreux dispositifs de
sécurisation des données évidemment je
tiens à rappeler que le compteur linky
compte en kilowattheures exactement
comme les anciens compteurs et donc
circulent en termes d'information
uniquement les données de consommation
n'ya pas votre nom ni votre prénom ni
votre numéro de téléphone la voyez nous
ne circulent que les données de
consommation dont c'est extrêmement
léger en termes de données transférées
merci à thomas à bordeaux pour ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur territorial d'aînés 10 dans
les yvelines merci d'être passé sur ce
plateau
c'est un défi annuel lancé par yvelines
environnement l'association a donné le
top départ de son jeu concours 2019 il
s'adresse aux jeunes yvelinois de 5 à 15
ans et aux personnes en foyer
d'hébergement le principe les
participants devront remplir une grille
de mots complété d'un dessin a réalisé
sur le thème nos amis les aliments de
nos saisons le bulletin d'inscription
est disponible dans les établissements
scolaires du département aux accueils de
loisirs ainsi que sur demande à tous les
guichet sncf des yvelines interview
collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude
nous avons choisi cette année le thème
des légumes car il nous semblait très
important de rappeler la façon dont ces
légumes sont cultivés et que si on mange
des fraises à noël et bien hélas elles
viennent de très loin ça veut dire des
avions
ça veut dire de la consommation de
kérosène ça veut dire
d'innombrables chose donc ce thème a
pour but de faire réfléchir les enfants
sur ces questions vous pouvez participer
à ce concours yvelines environnement
jusqu'au 13 avril les lauréats seront
récompensés le 21 mai prochain au palais
des congrès de versailles rendre les
maths attractive et ludique c'est la
mission que s'est donnée le
mathématicien et professeur en classes
préparatoires françois sauvageau à
travers son one man show il propose aux
enfants et leurs parents d'apprivoiser
cette science et du chiffre avec des
exemples du quotidien le reportage de
marie lehn yapi chinois cela commence
comme un cours de mathématiques
classique tien est sauvé les siens
mais très vite on en arrive à des tours
de magie pour moi c'est important de se
rendre compte que les mathématiques ce
n'est pas juste une et seulement
abstrait mais c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on a envie et qu'on peut voir au
quotidien et même c'est même tout dans
l'autre sens pour moi dans mon
expérience personnelle c'est le vécu qui
alimente les mathématiques depuis 20 ans
ce mathématicien s'engage dans des
actions pour démocratiser sa science
auprès du public
il apparaît notamment dans le film
documentaire d'olivier peillon comment
j'ai détesté les maths
il proposait samedi à la commanderie son
one man show détour pour nouer une
cravate sans la quitter des mains ou des
objets bistrot des théorèmes par exemple
ici je demande à voir qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on peut regarder là dessus
et je sais pas si vous voyez ici on peut
voir des formes un peu étrange que ce
soit des carrés des hexagones ou peut
être même le crâne de hamlet c'est ce
genre de choses ce une façon de se
réconcilier avec pythagore et tables de
multiplication c'était bien j'ai aimé et
avant ça m'a fait un peu plus aimer les
maths
oui j'ai bien aimé ça et ça m'a fait
enfin c'est que maintenant les maths
c'est pas compliqué enfin cia on peut
faire des trucs simples avec des maths
que j'ai trouvé c'est très ludique et ça
donne une autre proche des mathématiques
qu'on n'a pas forcément l'habitude on
pense que c'est une matière scientifique
qu'il faut beaucoup travailler pour y
arriver est finalement là on se rend
compte que on pouvait être aussi acteur
on réfléchissait fin j'ai trouvé ça très
sain par contre au delà de la magie
françois sauvageau ajout des
mathématiques à la danse au sein du
spectacle paradoxa qui se joue mardi 15
janvier au prix smile en cours et on
retrouve mélanie poquet pour son coup de
coeur culture bonsoir ça ce soir mélanie
vous nous emmener en voyage
oui soyez prêts à embarquer pour
l'odyssée d'ipo en 80 rêve hip hop c'est
hippocampe fou un rappeur accompagné de
luc adoriez musicien compositeur il vous
emmène en voyage à travers le monde
entier et pas seulement
l'odyssée 10 po et leurs toutes
dernières créations ils sont
actuellement en résidence à la mairie de
trappes pour finaliser le tout
notre première idée c'était quoi c'était
de mélanger la musique du monde avec le
hip hop et après avoir listé un petit
peu tous les tous les pays où tous les
genres musicaux qu'on pouvait mélanger
on s'est dit avec tout ça on peut
raconter une histoire et avoir fait le
scénario de du spectacle
voilà qu'on va jouer et vous avez
assisté à une répétition qu'est ce qui
en fait votre coup de coeur pourquoi
l'avoir sélectionné pour nous en fait
c'est le tout c'est le mélange scène
musiques images alors la mise en scène
est très épuré quelques les éléments
vont être ajoutés mais hippocampe fouet
les artistes qui l'accompagnent ont
choisi la simplicité pour le spectateur
parce que pour eux on travaille c'est
pas le plus simple
l'oeil par exemple n'est pas à tirer
dans tous les sens on se laisse penser
porté par les créations vidéo
les dessins et les animations qui sont
signés notamment yannick données et
chloride et sarah et cléo sarrazin la
musique est très actuel mais lucas
d'aurier et hippocampe fou y amène des
consonances cinématographique et
mondiale regardez plutôt
[Musique]
le jour le présent alors pour vous
laisser porter par l'odyssée d'ipo
rendez vous le samedi 19 janvier à 15
heures à la mairie de trappes et le
spectacle sera suivie par une rencontre
goûtait que les artistes hippocampe ou
et bien d'autres informations encore à
retrouver dans l'émission c'est une
culture présentée par vous mélanie merci
pour cette chronique est votre émission
à retrouver juste après ce journal
d'ailleurs c'est la fin de cette édition
vous pouvez bien sûr la retrouver en
replay complet ainsi que tous les
reportages sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]